paradise and this is chessable monsters
blitz game number two must win for a
niche and here we go with the black
pieces for a niche interesting prague
develops his knight first so he goes for
the retti remember that anish won in the
king's indian defense uh and a must-win
situation with black so he's been here
before but prague doesn't go for the
same variation prague doesn't occupy the
center with pawns he's gone for what we
call the double fee and keto look at the
two white bishops
on nice long diagonals and this is
regarded as a much safer line a much
less risky line
than the one practice previously
it's up to a niche to create something
he needs to win with black never easy to
do so and white's king very very safe in
this formation
i think this is following the game uh is
it magnus versus jordan um
[Music]
i'm pretty sure that this in the last
tour which ended up in a draw but a5 is
the first uh new move i think uh being
played by niche it looks like they're
moving a bit quicker now as well which
is a good sign because maybe they
adjusted a bit after that first game uh
but black winning this is gonna be tough
yeah they're in the zone now you can
tell anish is definitely in the zone as
simon says though winning this position
is tough because white has no weaknesses
and okay prague develops his knight
stopping the black a pawn from advancing
further but also getting ready to push
more pawns in the center for white
um it's just very very simple logical
play now for both sides and i think that
suits prague as white because he only
needs a draw okay giri gets ready to
push a pawn in the center i expect
prague to do the same
maybe he'll push upon now
it would be logical to do that
but he's taking his time before he makes
that decision and yup
and
well pragnanda has a choice here i think
he should if he wants to play it safe
probably the best thing is to capture
the pawn
no in the middle trade off a set of
pawns in the center don't let any
imbalances happen we saw when it was
really blocked up geary outplayed him in
the last game giri also outplayed him
last month in a blocked up structure
so i don't think prague should try to be
too ambitious here trade things off as
your vanco mentions just make the pawn
structure symmetrical if you can
i think that's a good rule in general
for viewers at home just don't take any
risks uh if you feel that you're playing
against an opponent who might
outmaneuver you yeah or who has better
nerves than you
and uh okay spending a bit of time now
though simon
good moment to do that do you think yeah
i mean he's i guess so he's got to try
to decide what structure to go to and i
think i agree with both you just this is
the best move you only need a draw get a
symmetrical structure a draw becomes a
lot more likely just put a rook on the
open file play some normal natural moves
you don't need to really overthink this
position quite yet
and
again i did say it's going to be hard
for anish to win it looks you know these
kind of positions
you need to play extremely well to to
get any advantage in and much better
opening choice i think this time for for
prague rather than going into some messy
uh complex structure he only needs to
draw with the white pieces yeah
it feels like he's definitely learned
from his defeat a couple of games ago
and i like this night move it looks a
bit strange to bring the knight back to
block the white queen but the white
knight is going to actually leap forward
in front of its other knight and those
two white knights together will control
a whole bunch of central squares so gary
also remaneuvering his pieces
and okay prague blocks things up you
don't want to allow your opponent to
gain too much space with their pawns so
you have to block with your pawn
sometimes and here we go gary trying to
confuse prague attacking the white queen
will the white queen move there we go
a pawn could also have blocked but then
white would have maybe loosened his own
pawn structure so the white queen safe
and
yeah simple on this square
remember anish he has to win his game to
take it to an armageddon tiebreak game
prague he needs a draw and now the bar
goes up for him yeah i'm surprised it's
gone up that much
i quite like white's position but
it looks roughly balanced still
for now the one thing i think that is
really not great in anish's position is
the black knight on the left side of the
board because it can't jump anywhere and
look at white's queen now he's putting
some pressure on that knight not
attacking it but that black knight now
ties down the black queen it's on a bad
circuit
i don't think anish likes his position
yeah and i have to say i'm really
impressed by pragananda's play i love
the way he's placed his queen on the
third row and now he's just maneuvering
his knights
around um i was thinking that he
actually might maneuver the c3 knight
away
move it somewhere to put pressure but
so far model play by pranglander yep not
taking any risks and we talked about
symmetry this pawn structure if you look
at the right half of the board
completely symmetrical left side of the
board almost symmetrical simply no
weaknesses in practice position how is
giri ever going to win this game he will
need to hope that prague cracks under
the pressure under the tension later
okay black's now uh his knights are
re-maneuvering around and it might be
time for your idea ivanka remove the
other white knight or the white dark
squared bishop
or you could make an argument for kind
of stacking up the white rooks in the
central line on the d-file
this i think black was going to reroute
his bishop so this this is also quite
clever maybe because now um black maybe
wanted to get that bishop around the
angles and you can just exchange off
more pieces now stopping black's bishop
getting out at the moment black's dark
square bishop uh the one in front of his
king is just looking at a pawn so it's
kind of blocked in and this last move it
kind of indicates that anish
hasn't really got much he can do here so
this is you know especially after that
one it's looking at the moment like
prague is keeping everything
really well under control here and
probably has a better position yeah
that white bishop that white dart squad
bishop is like a bone in the throat of
an ishgiri's position how is he going to
remove it he has to trade off later on
here we go just defending everything
look at the two kings symmetry again
because that is the safest square for
them uh having a king on this square
anish tried it in the last game as well
it's very effective it's very safe
usually
and i'm expecting a niche to as simon
mentioned at some point try to use the
black dark square bishop to trade off
white's very strong bishop there but not
easy to arrange maybe
black central pawn also under fire
it's all about prague in this position
wow yeah and i actually see anish gary
actually tweeted before the blitz star
break started
he wrote grandpa fighting
after winning in game four he definitely
is older than pregnant even if anish is
still very young
but the 16 year old it's looking good
for him i guess then to
to get that draw and get to the big
final it's looking very good anisha is
only 10 years older than prague but we i
mean he's been around forever in here
he's been one of the world's elite for a
long long time
grandpa grandpa fighting and graham for
thinking right now
it's very hard for black to do anything
here that's a problem while white white
has maybe some moves we can prove like i
think you mentioned just doubling the
rooks here white can take over that open
file um so whoa look at this whoa
this is a weird weird move
i mean
i mean don't take the bishop as the
first thing
to avoid we can show this quickly while
prague thinks this is just a poisoned
bishop simply this bishop's moved to
this square willingly of course it's a
one move trap if you take it the black
knight jumps forward with a check and
winning the white queen on the next move
so of course that bishop cannot be
touched but the problem is it can just
be ignored as well prague happy to move
his rook forward now he's going to stack
up his rooks on the open file giri's
whole idea is that after dropping his
bishop back the reason he got his bishop
out the way is that his rook defends his
central pawn so now he's hoping to trade
bishops
and at least if the white bishop
disappears he has much more room to
breathe meanwhile this black bishop is
weirdly placed and it will continue to
be for the next few moves we'll see a
bishop trade on this square in a moment
and still gary under some pressure
prague
rock solid as white clever idea though i
mean i think this is the only way that
black could get this exchange of bishops
off so you know nice
nice sort of uh thinking there but must
still be white with the advantage
because this open file and just the
central squares that he controls here um
in the position maybe you can move your
king back now just make your opponent
take your knight even yeah something
like this weird move you know get out of
here
these men just came back so still simon
just uh make that bishop move now
because you're threatening to take it in
this position
so uh but i i don't see how anisha is
going to win this at the moment but they
they are both under two minutes so it is
possible there's so many pieces around
and
pawns and everything around that white
king yeah
that's i think exactly why pregnant
chose this opening and a very good
choice when you only need a draw with
white why not just kind of set up this
beautiful structure where you'll never
ever get checkmated
meanwhile i do like what anish has done
at least to alleviate the pressure
now after these sets of trades
two sets of minor pieces have come off
the board and white's rooks are dominant
but there's nowhere for them to actually
go
and sometimes there will be threats of
breaking the connection between the two
white rooks
and yeah i'm expecting prague now to
maybe retreat he pushes harry the h1 oh
i'm i'm normally a big fan of this move
but here i wasn't so sure about that i
actually expected
the bishop to relocate to a better
diagonal and uh now anish is doing what
uh
he should do
improve the placing of the knights
that black knight maneuver is actually
going to be very strong watch out for
that black knight to leap forward into
the center of the board and then into
the d4 square if you look at the d4
square that's a dream for black's
knights prague meanwhile
retreating
it feels like he's getting a bit nervous
though definitely i mean it feels like
anisha's is
showing a bit of his experience taking
over uh a little bit he was definitely
worse
and now now
i mean
i was going to say is he better but i
don't i mean he might be at least equal
now white's bishop is not a great piece
in these positions and i think ivanka's
idea of rebooting it also made a lot of
sense maybe you could still try that at
some point but
black's comfortable now at least
yeah black's very very comfortable i
think the main thing for black was
because he was cramped earlier we talked
about black having a lack of space he's
traded stuff off and he continues to do
so he offers a trade of all of the rooks
i mean
if i were in a must-win situation i
don't think i would have rushed this
decision um this decision he could have
gone for over the next few turns but now
if i were prague i would just hurry to
trade off all the rooks
uh i would i would just be saying thank
you you've made my plan a lot clearer
i'm heading towards the draw yeah prague
has also ticked under the minute so
getting rid of pieces must be a great
idea yeah for break yeah it means that
he'll get some extra time but you know
he chooses to take a step back with the
rook standing his ground going very
passive though isn't he as well
i mean you don't when you've got to draw
you know don't go too passive and
they're both getting under a minute now
really but it's prague who's
much shorter time 40 seconds left and
he's getting he's going the wrong way in
this game things are going slightly
wrong for him his track record with
white against giri is not good he lost a
couple of times in the tour last uh last
month and now lost again a couple of
games ago
normally prague is great with white but
against giri somehow
not so easy and okay a trade of one set
of rooks it's still
roughly in the balanced but black is the
one who has made progress over the last
15 moves
hmm well it is that problem right when
you only need a draw and then you play
too much on the draw you get nervously
wrong yeah you take negative decisions
and we praised his opening his middle
game was great as well but
after that just retreating slightly
swapping the wrong pieces now the black
queen
inching her way forward
interesting decision is uh setting up a
trick is it or or i think a nasty trick
in the position uh maybe just while
prague oh he's down to 20 seconds maybe
we can show this quickly javanka's idea
queen takes pawn okay it would have been
a blunder taking this pawn i think
because the knight jumps out the way
attacking the queen but also attacking
this bishop and uh there's no real safe
way you can defend so okay
of course prague dodged that he dropped
his bishop back to a nice safe square
but now the black knights are jumping in
this square could be used at some point
now the two black knights are ganged up
against this pawn it's all about the
knights and they're dancing
are they going to create enough
for anishigiri to win this game
he maybe can even offer an exchange of
queens which generally you don't want to
do
when you're trying to win but the black
queen might be to come down two squares
uh but look at the time as well they're
both now under 20 seconds
uh with black
probably having a more comfortable
position but he's got to move
and he has he's going for some tricks
he's going for the mating ideas now so
this black knight is threatening the f2
pawn
that white pawn on the f2 square only
defended by white's king okay good move
i think from prague getting his knight
out the way the white rook now defends
along the second rank
uh yeah i think both sides kind of have
to get into defensive mode and uh well
anish carries on with maneuvering the
knight and the knight is threatening to
jump forward and all sorts of attacks
happening bishop comes to attack knight
is in the middle yeah that was a massive
trick in the last position white's rook
was attacked if white's rook had gone up
to capture the black rook white the
black queen would have come in with a
nasty checkmate but look at this every
move from geary is a threat
the white queen was attacked stepped
back and now protecting his own knight
geary you see a trade however oh what's
happening here oh that i think you're
interested in a porn white's one of pawn
yeah wow incredible gary i think he
attacked one move too many and now he's
just got support not just that the
queens are off ah prague is almost safe
now he's almost home
that was so quick that was so quick
blink and you miss it it was like
the speed they moved those tactics
incredible
and well he's a pawn up in an ending now
this must surely be uh the end um and
it's it's a very good pawn as well look
at this white a pawn this white a pawn
is running up the board and giri leans
back
he knows this one it's almost over and
he's given up yeah takes it wow 16 year
old pragmatanda is ready for the final
and chessable monsters knocking out
anitgiri